well if we continue with the weather now
because the Met Office is warning of
continued severe weather in many parts
of the UK in place until at least
Thursday of this week there are yellow
warnings for ice in the southeast of
England and snow and ice in Northern
Scotland and also coastal areas off
North East England Sky meet George's
Steph goulter has the very latest what
we have sort of lost today is a little
bit of the snow that we were seeing
yesterday and overnight so yeah we had
around 10 centimeters of snow maybe 12
down in the Southeast corner and it was
certainly cold everywhere so if we take
a look at the graphics then we can see
that it's very it was coldest in the
Northern parts of Scotland we had minus
15.7 that was the coldest we had in
Braemar and that's the coldest that
we've had since February 2021 so very
very cold and elsewhere also well below
freezing for most of us as well now what
we'll see as we head through the next
day or so is less wintry weather but we
are going to have another sort of Arctic
blast down from the north so it's going
to be the northern part of Scotland
where we see the heavier snow as we head
through the next couple of days
elsewhere further south again as the
temperatures drop away overnight it's
going to be bitterly cold and this time
we'll have a problem with freezing fog
now the problem with freezing fog is
that it doesn't clear very easily and so
for some of us it's going to stay very
gray and gloomy and bitterly cold
throughout the day further north for the
Northern parts of Scotland we'll stay
with the snow so it's staying cold if
anything more of an Arctic blast it's
not letting up anytime soon
a week of widespread